en esta ocasión vamos a ver algunos
ejemplos de límites
muchos de estos ejemplos tú te los
puedes encontrar algún día en un examen
o en general cuando quieras resolver un
límite para trabajar estos ejemplos es
muy necesario que creemos un olfato
matemático y mucha intuición tampoco
debemos de olvidar que el concepto del
límite es una idea fundamental para
entender todo el cálculo por ejemplo
tomemos el límite cuando extiende al
vamos a tomarlo al menos uno de alguna
función y tomemos la expresión ya se
tengo una idea de expresión 2 x + 2
muy bien y todo esto vamos a dividirlo
entre x 1 quedó perfecto y antes de que
pasa cualquier cosa me gustaría que
observaremos lo siguiente qué va a pasar
si sustituimos el menos 1 adentro de
nuestra expresión es decir si ponemos 2
x menos 1 y a eso le sumamos 2 y lo
dividimos todo entre menos uno más uno
muy bien pero 2 x menos uno más dos pues
claramente cero y menos uno más uno pues
también a cero y nosotros ya sabemos
cuánto deseo entre cero no claro será
entre 0 es indefinido ya habíamos visto
antes se acuerda algo que esté dividido
entre 0 siempre va a ser indefinido pero
fíjense bien lo que estoy diciendo
cuando yo meto el menos 1 en la
expresión y sustituyó me da un resultado
indefinido ok pero será acaso este el
límite que queremos para resolver esta
pregunta vamos a tratar de buscar medios
alternativos uno de ellos va a ser hacer
una gráfica recuerden que es muy
importante que pueda tienen un problema
en matemático pueden analizarlo por un
comportamiento gráfico bien hagamos una
gráfica
qué les parece que estos vayan a ser
nuestros seres
vamos a regresar a nuestra función
original y vamos a tratar de escribirla
de una manera distinta usando de por
medio conocimiento que ya habíamos
obtenido gracias al álgebra escribiremos
el numerador 2 x + 2 de la forma todos x
x + + está fallando mi pluma
+ 1 si es miren 2 x + 2 es 2 veces x 1 y
todo esto lo vamos a dividir entre la
expresión que tenemos de x + 1
muy bien si vemos que esta expresión y
esta expresión son distintos de 0
entonces lo que vamos a poder hacer
esperen alto ahí tengo una mejor idea
vamos a llamar esto de una vez
efe de x este nuevo nombre nos va a
servir porque si tenemos una x distinta
de menos 1 entonces este término y este
término lo podemos cancelar esto nos da
pie a poder llamar nuestra función de
una manera distinta vamos a llamar a la
función debido a dos casos cuáles serán
nuestros casos pues será 2 si x va a ser
un valor distinto menos 1
y recordemos qué pasaba cuando x valía
menos 1 pues nuestra función era
indefinida entonces pondremos aquí
indefinido pues cuando x sea igual a
menos 1
no vayamos a olvidar que hemos podido
llamar así a nuestra función cuando x es
distinto de menos 1 debido a que
nosotros teníamos una expresión la
expresión que tenemos acá pudiendo
reducir el x + 1 el numerador y el x + 1
del denominador bueno y como se va a ver
ahora la gráfica de nuestra función para
esto vamos a hacer las cosas más
coloridas cambiamos el color rojo para
ponerlo más entretenido perfecto tomemos
que aquí sea el número 2 y este de aquí
ese va a ser nuestro menos 1 entonces
nuestra gráfica siempre es 2 siempre
para todos valores 2 f x es igualdad 2
es más pongamos de 123 para que sepamos
no pinta otra vez 3 para que se vea más
claro y el menos 1 que pasa tenemos un
agujero y después del -1 otra vez toda
nuestra gráfica valdo igualados que
hermosa forma de ver un límite de una
manera completamente gráfica
voy a cambiar de color para enseñarles
lo que sigue observen que cuando nos
acercamos esta vez al menos uno por la
izquierda nuestro valor de fx va a ser
22 22 22 vienen menos 1 tenemos un
pequeño agujero ahora bien si nos
acercamos al menos uno por la derecha
nuestra función va a ir saliendo 22 222
no les parece esto completamente
sorprendente y es que aunque en el -1 es
indeterminado el límite cuando extiende
menos 1 de nuestra expresión es 2 voy a
hacer una línea para no confundirnos y
seguir con el análisis
miren acabo de probar de una manera no
muy formal pero eso sí basada de ideas
completamente de álgebra es decir que al
cele el de que es más uno entre el x + 1
de mi expresión pues recordemos que eso
es 1 y con estas ideas acabamos de ver
que el límite cuando existiendo al menos
uno
creo que hemos creado una intuición
bastante buena en este momento
e insisto aunque tal vez no hemos
conseguido la demostración más formal
hemos hecho una cosa bastante buena que
nos va a servir mucho en el futuro que
ya están padres hemos tenido el día de
hoy y es que esperen esperen se me ha
quedado con una idea muy buena tomemos
una calculadora y vamos a ver qué pasa
en puntos cercanos al menos 1 es decir
tomemos por ejemplo efe de menos 1.001 o
tal vez tomemos por ejemplo
efe de punto 9 y de punto menos 999 y
para qué quiero hacer esto pues si
nosotros sustituimos en la calculadora
unos puntos muy muy cercanos al menos 1
nos va a dar como resultado el valor de
2 perfecto creo que hasta aquí hemos
hecho un muy buen trabajo ok pero ahora
pasemos a otro ejemplo vamos a ver ahora
vamos a ver él está fallando la pluma
otra vez a ver ahora sí vamos a ver el
límite cuando x se va a acercar esta vez
a 0 de la expresión 1 / x como se verá
la gráfica de esta expresión es claro
que con la intuición que hemos creado
hasta ahorita ya podemos ver que uno
entre x cuando x es 0 pues es una cosa
indeterminada
es decir indefinida vamos a llamar de
una vez a esto nuestra función
efe de de problemas con la pluma
de fx igual a 1 entre x
y como ya sabemos en el cielo nuestra
función es indefinida tengo una idea
mejor vamos a hacer de una vez una tabla
para poder comparar los datos de fx que
pondremos del lado derecho y vamos a
poner otra vez con pluma bien y vamos a
poner x del lado izquierdo es muy claro
que cuando x vale 0 pues nuestra fx es
indefinida al menos de eso ya estábamos
seguros no pinte mi pluma bien ya está
pintado mi pluma en este caso es
indefinido cuando x vale 0 muy bien pero
qué pasa si ahora tomamos un valor muy
cercano al cero por ejemplo es menos
punto 0 1 si nosotros sustituimos en la
calculadora 1 entre menos punto 01
obtendremos el resultado menos 100
perfecto pero ahora qué pasa si nos
acercamos más por la izquierda tomamos
el valor menos punto 001 ok y si este
valor lo sustituimos a nuestra función
original en la calculadora nos dará como
resultado menos
no pinte mi pluma - sigue sin pintar mi
pluma hay algo muy raro aquí con
nuestras herramientas algo le está
pasando mi pluma que podemos hacer
aunque ya ve de esta herramienta suena
bien a ver probemos - no pinta houston
creo que tenemos un problema con la
computadora y sin pluma no me va a poder
ser posible seguir el vídeo que haremos
ya se creo que vamos a tener que dejar
para el vídeo siguiente tendría que
hacerlo en una computadora y hacer que
mi pluma regrese a la vida pero ustedes
no se preocupen nos vemos en el próximo
vídeo y no se lo pierdan